[Musique]
julienne et est un jeune homme
remarquable son surnom était le magicien
parce qu'il était toujours capable
d'élaborer une nouvelle approche de voir
les choses autrement
jolie n était chez moi et nous prenions
le thé je crois que je ne suis pas sûr
c'était en 2006 quelque chose comme ça
c'est tout en tout cas et jolie anne m'a
dit qu'il voulait lancer un site wiki et
que celui qui concernerait les fuites et
que les gens qui voudraient divulguer
des informations pour qu'elles soient
rendues publiques utiliserait tort
[Musique]
avez vous essayé de le mettre en garde à
ce moment là la bataille
non non pourquoi c'était un jeune homme
avec toute la vie devant lui
on ne donne pas d'avertissement à
quelqu'un comme lui on lui demande
comment puis-je td j'ai toujours pris à
coeur cette métaphore de la nature vit
dangereusement ta vie dangereusement
dans le clip ne tourne pas autour du pot
n'ai pas peur de l'ombre de voix que
fait ce que tu as à faire et affrontent
les conséquences du mieux possible
c'est cette ligne de conduite ce qui m'a
guidé toute ma vie
[Musique]
le son
ça
abattus les instants
[Musique]